[Music]
i think jewelry is the most magical
thing you can wear
for something so small that can fit in
the palm of your hand it can hold a
world of memories and emotions
it has the ability to reach into the
past as well as reach into the future
and i find that endearingly romantic
a lot of jewelry embodies a lot of human
suffering
whether that is the suffering of minors
whether it's the environmental
disruption they produce something very
beautiful
but it often comes at a kind of nasty
cost
the more people get concerned about that
the more
they are open
to alternatives
[Music]
in this place we mine the sky to get the
gases we need to make diamonds
our entire ingredient list is the wind
the sun the rain and atmospheric carbon
that's it no more
there is still so much to explore in the
world of science and also material
innovation and how to turn something
negative and wasteful into the things
that we want
ana balachan is telling a new 21st
century romantic story about jewelry
which is that the designer's eye
is just as important as the materials
they're made from
i've made pieces from everyone from
beyonce to rihanna to taylor swift julia
roberts lupita nyong'o
from the oscars to the grammys
when i told people i wanted to create
fine and high jewelry using laboratory
grown gemstones people thought i was
crazy
[Music]
there are several pieces from my old
collection that i treasure
one of them is this ring from the late
andrew grima
this was one of his sort of
architectural inspired rings that he
designed in the 70s
he is known as the father of
contemporary jewelry design
he famously said that a 50 carat
topaz can become a work of art that can
be worn and enjoyed yet a 60s of carat
diamond needs to be locked up in a vault
traditionally
high fine jewelry is notoriously
exclusive i wanted it to be more
accessible because it is the ultimate
craftsmanship it's the ultimate sort of
handcrafted treasure
that shouldn't just be accessible by so
few people in the world
the most beautiful colors and geometries
and textures come from nature
and a lot of the times when i design i'm
merely trying to capture that moment of
magic i see in nature transforming that
into something that can be worn
i would always start by having a
sketchbook and my drawing easel and
going to draw subjects that interest me
just seeing
something ordinary as something
extraordinary
the two pieces we are making are a pair
of brooches inspired by a blade of grass
with morning dew drops so the running
through the veins
[Music]
i will then start to sketch on each
piece of jewelry in pencil
and then from those initial sketches
that could be hundreds of them
i would then take sort of my favorite
ones and then transition them into
paints which is known as jewelry
renderings that will essentially be like
a map for the craftsmen to to work with
[Music]
i was trained very traditionally at art
college as a fine jewelry designer
working with sort of mind gemstones and
i think what really sort of changed my
trajectory was when i went on my
honeymoon to sri lanka
i knew that sri lanka was famous for its
color stones and so i made few visits to
latissional mines in the area
these are some of the most precious
commodities in the world
and yet the people who mine these stones
live some of the harshest conditions in
the world
it just didn't make any sense and that's
when i began my research into laboratory
grown gemstones gemstones cultivated in
a science lab rather than mine from the
ground
so i'm sat here in the cotswolds uh in
our lab the place where we
created the process to make these
diamonds from the sky
the most permanent form of carbon that
we know of is a diamond we set out to do
this in order to
lock carbon up into a permanent form
it's like a carbon capture and storage
project
what we learned very quickly was that
there's not a lot of carbon in a diamond
actually maybe four grams in a one carat
stone but when we looked at the diamond
mining industry we found that to make
that same one carat stone requires the
digging of 1100 tons of rock and the
exposure of 30 tons of toxic metal to
the environment
the consumption of 5 000 liters of water
and the production of half a ton of
greenhouse gas
so the beers have made famous this
slogan diamonds are forever
what they don't tell you is that the
impacts of diamond mining are forever so
the holes in the big diamond mines in
russia for example are so big you can
see them from orbit
and so the avoided carbon
that we are
achieving through making diamonds from
the sky is way bigger than the carbon
that we're actually pulling from the sky
and locking up
and what we make are diamonds they're
chemically molecularly identical to
diamonds that are dug out of the earth
lab-grown diamonds uh
as a thing have been around for
decades but they were small and they
were used for industrial diamonds
gem type diamonds have begun to be a
major
industry in more or less the last 10
years
the knowledge that they exist is
becoming greater but people still have a
confusion
because there have been for a long long
time
imitation diamonds of cubic zirconia
things that look like diamonds but are
not diamonds a lab-grown diamond it's
not an imitation it's it's not like
vegan meat or something it is the same
thing made in a different way
so the magic starts where we first pull
carbon dioxide from the atmosphere with
a machine from switzerland
we then split rain water into hydrogen
and oxygen
and we feed a combination of hydrogen
and carbon dioxide
to our bugs
these are ancient bacteria that take
these two ingredients and stitch them
together into methane
and then we feed the methane along with
some other gases into our diamond ovens
so in our diamond oven we might lay out
16 diamond seeds in a square pattern
and they live in this ball of plasma
where we feed it with gas
it runs at about a thousand degrees
centigrade so it's very hot
but within this plasma ball we can turn
our gases into a crystalline structure
that is a diamond
and at the end of two weeks we pull out
a square like this
it's like a window with a with a black
edge
and we chop this block up into 16
individual stones with our laser
and then we trim each one of those to
remove the black growth from around the
edges and then we have what we call
roughs
little squares or cubes of material that
looks a little translucent
and we send it away and it gets cut and
polished into the shape that we all
traditionally associate with the diamond
and this is the
the biggest one yes the biggest yeah
and any given batch will come out with a
different color or clarity but we are
achieving quality in the top one percent
of all diamonds we know this we send
them away for assessment in the same way
that diamonds ripped out of the earth
are sent for assessment
and we get back the same basic metrics
although many
laboratories do work with renewable
energy
the source of the original elements
often have to be taken from existing
minerals and i think the excitement with
what sky diamond is doing is that it
actually takes something that we don't
want something that is a waste and turn
that into something that is treasured
at retail mined diamonds traditional
diamonds cost two or three times more
uh than uh lab grown diamonds and i
think it's kind of an old-fashioned idea
that
that uh luxury
requires the most expensive materials
you can also use more unique designs you
can use
a more sort of ingenuity
many potential sources of value can make
something luxurious
i think for a younger generation the
idea that you can have this scientific
breakthrough to create this special
stone
has a kind of romance
to it just as the old diamond is forever
slogan had a different kind of romance
when working with recycled gold you can
purchase the pallets of gold that
actually come from different sources
whether it's from tech industries
extracted from discarded electronics
like computer chips and mobile phones
and also from
repurposing the antique jewelry so all
of this metal is then re-melted together
and refined into the pellets that we are
using today
the process of creating this piece
involves first a wax model of the blade
of grass
so like carving of a miniature sculpture
from the wax model it is then lost wax
casted into gold
one of the oldest technique within fine
jewelry
so how it works is by setting that wax
piece inside a plaster cast
and then melting gold pellets and
pouring the metal into the plaster cast
it will then fill the void where the wax
was and so you lose the piece of wax
hence the term lost wax casting
and once the the metal is cooled down
when you open up your cast you will get
the piece that resembles exactly your
original wax but in solid gold
[Music]
and from that you would then start
working on finishing the piece
by filing and assembling
and within the gold piece we will then
work on the setting of each gemstone
a piece of jewelry finally sort of come
to life in those final stages of
polishing it
because that's when you see the
transformation of a piece that is maybe
quite dirty and quite gritty and that
final polish gives it that shine
the fine jewelry industry has always
been about prestige whether it's showing
off your wealth or showing off your
power
what conveys prestige changes over time
and if that includes being concerned
about the materials that things are made
not just that they be expensive or rare
but that they be ethically sourced
you're going to have to take that into
consideration and that opens the way for
lab-grown gems among other things
to doubters i would say come back in 20
years
come back in 20 years and see
see where we are
i suspect that
we will no longer even be talking about
this distinction there will just be
diamonds
[Music]
lady gaga wore a pair of our feather
earrings with laboratory grown
tourmalines and that was for me the
first time so seeing it out on the red
carpet
it always blows my mind when a celebrity
wears one of our pieces
i think in the beginning
people choose it predominantly for the
design and for its aesthetics
but when they find out more about the
sustainability and the ethical sort of
ethos behind what we do and the
reasoning and why we use certain
materials they become much more
supportive
the other
pair of the brooch features tahitian
pearls with anodized aluminium
[Music]
so pearls used to be the most precious
gems the gems that represented
wealth that represented power you see a
lot of them in renaissance art
showing how rich the person wearing them
is and the reason the pearls were so
valuable is that they are extremely rare
in nature but in the late 19th century
someone figured out that you could
culture pearls so that you could have a
reliable supply of pearls
it became affordable because of this
technological breakthrough but if you
owned an old string of
pearls that was worth the
price of a building in manhattan which
is a real example uh
suddenly that string of pearls was worth
a lot less and that is the kind of
dynamic
that lab-grown diamonds could present
for the diamond industry
for this particular piece i've chosen to
use pearls from kamoko pearls i'm always
fascinated by the incredible colors they
are able to achieve where you get these
pistachio hues to golden to silvery gray
to midnight through blue
i came across comoca pose around two
three years ago
what really drew me to them was the way
they formed their pearls is a perfect
example of how
people can work with nature in harmony
to actually
improve the environment around them
so traditionally when it comes to
pearl farming
water jets are used to clean the oysters
and by using water jets it changes the
current surrounding the oysters
it can damage the coral reefs and change
the ph level of the water
and actually disrupts the whole
ecosystem
kamoka pearls utilizes exotic fishes to
clean their oysters
not only have they been able to
regenerate the reef surrounding their
they've also been able to regenerate
some endangered species in the
ecosystems which is phenomenal
[Music]
making jewelry is a messy process and i
always say it is like beauty emerges
from organized chaos
the process to make this piece involves
hand shaping aluminium metal
piercing it out of the sheet using a
piercing saw
and it's very much guided by subtle
changes of directions to pierce the
piece out into the form
and then molding it into a blade of
grass
chasing is setting a piece of so sheet a
metal that is essentially flat into a
platform where you shape the metal by
knocking and tapping on the hammer
so every vein and every grain has been
worked on individually and organically
aluminium is so much lighter than gold
or platinum or silver so i'm able to
work with much so bolder geometry
and at the same time it is about
creating a new color palette that mimics
nature
because aluminium can be colored in a
myriad of different ways compared to
traditional precious metals
you run an electric current into a bath
where
the metal is then submerged into sort of
different tanks and beakers
that allows the color to be imbued into
the aluminium
i've chosen a specific type of pearl
that reflects the the colors in the
leaves
and
to set the pearl into aluminium we then
create a cup with a pin in the center
which is known as the setting
the pearl is then drilled
and then to secure it in place we use a
resin
[Music]
i see this pair of brooches
being equally shared between sort of
partners and family members
equally worn by men and women at the
same time
they are inspired by the same elements
presented in a different language yet
they complement each other in the same
way
[Music]
i think the future of
fine jewelry really is about
sustainable and ethical and mindful
operations in every
sense and it's being able to learn from
the past
to offer different perspective in the
present
always in mind for a better future
i suppose this is my one of my favorite
quotes by maya angelos do the best you
can until you know better and when you
know better do better
[Music]
you